Well, good morning church, uh, grace
and peace to you from God, our father
and the Lord Jesus Christ.
I pray that you've had a good week thawing out in some ways.
Uh, unfortunately our building didn't do that very well
as we had a pipe burst back there
and it, uh, flooded classrooms down into the worship center,
all into the lobby and even down into the cafe.
And, uh, so yeah,
but we're grateful that had a bunch
of people helping clean up,
had a restoration company get out here pretty quickly
and that the Lord is still good.
Amen. Yeah,
just gonna be a little flexibility over the next couple.
Hopefully not too long,
but weeks maybe of adjusting, moving, seeing some
drywall ripped off again.
Here we go, right? So, yeah.
But, uh, just another quick update.
I am having arthroscopic surgery on my knee tomorrow,
scheduled for tomorrow at least,
and, uh, clean up the meniscus a little bit.
So appreciate your prayers for that.
But if you're new around here, we are excited
that you would choose to welcome to worship with us today.
We hope you are welcomed and encouraged
and, uh, felt like you connect here.
We'd love to help you do that.
Uh, we know it's hard to jump into a new place
and still wanna help you as best we can do that.
So please come let us know who you are either here in the
front, there's a QR code in the seat back in front of you,
or the new here area out there.
We'd love to just say hi to you that way.
But we are journeying through, uh, the core doctrines
of our faith in this series
that we're calling First Things First.
And so let's just remember where we've come so far.
You see the video weekly,
but uh, we're gonna just kinda recap a little bit.
And so what was the first big rock
that we studied a couple weeks ago?
Anybody remember Revelation?
Yeah, that's right. Okay,
so we're gonna put that one in here.
Revelation that God has told us about himself.
Otherwise we wouldn't know much if anything about him. Okay?
So that was the first week, then the second one last week.
Uh, what was that one? Man,
we're really on ball with this, aren't we?
Uh, the attributes of God, right? Yeah.
A couple of you got that one.
This was the fact of what God is and who God is.
Remember, we're putting these things in first
'cause they're the most important things.
So, uh, then we're gonna get to today.
Now, this one is one of the most important, yet one
of the most difficult of rocks
that we will study in this way.
It is the Trinity. The Trinity.
So that is one foundational doctrine today.
And more than any other, this is the distinctive belief
that is biblical Christianity.
Th this is also even separating us from groups
that would claim to be Christian as well.
This one will be distinct from that as we get into it.
Again, though, let me just be clear,
it is incredibly difficult for us as humans who are limited
to grasp this idea of the Trinity.
So you might be tempted right now, like, boy, I'm not ready
to think this early in the morning.
I'm just gonna check out, please don't,
because I, I read this longer
quote as it's been said this way.
Here's the beautiful thing. You don't need
to fully understand the Trinity to worship the Trinity.
Pray to the Trinity and enter into the life of the Trinity.
They tell me that deep within the core of the sun,
the temperature is 27 million degrees.
The pressure is 340 billion times what is here on Earth.
And in the sun's core, that insanely hot temperature
and unthinkable pressure combined
to create nuclear reactions in each reaction,
four protons fused together to create one alpha particle,
which is 0.7% less massive than the four protons.
The difference in mass is expelled this energy
and through a process called convection,
this energy from the core of the sun reaches the surface
where it's expelled as heat and light.
Now, that was all kind of interesting, but you know what?
I didn't need to know all that in order to get a tan.
So listen, as we study this today,
there's gonna be a whole lot of questions left unanswered.
Much of this is gonna be hard for us to understand
because the reality of this is, it is a mystery.
The Trinity is a mystery.
We're trying to materialize something that is immaterial.
We we have limited human language
that is incapable of describing something that's
beyond creation.
But that does not mean we shouldn't try
to understand better, right?
Because while the Trinity is a mystery, yes, we can learn
to speak well of this topic
and how to speak well about it.
We're just gonna have to be really careful
as we do it, right?
So even as I sit here
and I'm teaching this for the next few minutes, like
in many ways I'm walking a knife edge.
I don't want to detract from the glory of God in any way,
And I don't want to drift into heresy that is
so easy to do with this topic.
And we'll talk about some of those things.
And so there's like this sense of, of excitement
because I, I'm, I, I have grown more this week
in my theological understanding than probably the five years
before that, that I've been here
because it forced me to study deeply
in a hard, hard topic.
But I, I just really wanna be careful with it.
And we need to be careful as we go.
And so, so lemme just be clear,
we're all walking this journey together.
Like I'm growing, I'm learning, I'm experiencing things
and, and seeing things.
We're asking questions, we're all seeking answers.
Like we're all gonna walk away from this
with more questions in some ways.
And so as we study these kinds of things, all the big rocks,
let's be humble and,
and let's trust God in it,
that he will grow our understanding,
he will grow our knowledge.
And in that he will grow our love for him as well.
So let's ask him for some help.
Now, God, thank you for, for the ideas
that, that we have seen the last couple weeks of
you telling us about yourself
and you telling us what you are, who you are.
This is one of those huge pieces of that.
And it's so far beyond us God.
So lead us to see a, just a glimpse today, all of us kids,
students, adults, that we all walk away with some measure
of deeper understanding and greater love for you.
But Holy Spirit, we need your help for that.
We need you to be the, the revealer of truth
that you say you would be to guide us into all truth.
Start with that today, God, for your glory
and our good in Jesus authority.
Amen. So we're gonna walk a journey
today to try to understand.
So first what we need to see is
what I've just talked termed here, the equation
of the Trinity students.
This is math class, right?
The equation of the trinity,
and what do we even mean when we say trinity?
Let's just get that on the table first.
We'll break the word down first.
So you have try, which means three,
and you have unity, which means one.
So you might even say try unity Trinity
three in one, one in three.
That's Trinity.
And so lemme give you just a couple phrases that you might
somewhat simply be able to say
what we're talking about here.
There's only one God,
that God exists eternally in three persons,
father, son, spirit,
and these three are equal in divinity
and possess the same essence.
Now you're like, that's not simple.
Okay, well, I get it right, but,
but those statements don't build off each other.
Like you don't start with one sequentially to the next one.
It it, it's also like we, we have
to accept them all simultaneously.
And this is where it starts to get a
little, little difficult.
Accept them simultaneously.
Again, one God, three persons, same divine essence.
I know this is hard, so, so
because we're visual people,
I'm gonna give you a couple classic illustrations
for the Trinity and you see 'em on the screen.
You've, you've probably seen these in some way before.
Now there's a danger as soon as I do this, there's a danger
because pictures are always limited.
Like the, there's you,
you cannot fully describe the trinity.
Even with pictures like this, even
with multiple pictures put together,
you can't get all the way there,
but they can help us a little bit.
So they're not just wa baby out with bath water, right?
Like a little bit of help here
where you can see on the left, just as I explained those,
those levels, those uh, phrases, the one of the left,
you can see that each person is fully God,
but the father is not the son.
The son is not the spirit.
The spirit's not the father, right?
You can see that there's three persons, but one God
and they're not the same.
The problem here, just look at the left one,
the problem here is that that can lead us to think
that there are parts of God
That's not helpful because there's been said
before, all that is in God is God, right?
So we're not saying like composition,
these three make up parts of God a third, a third, a third.
No, that's not what we're saying with that. It's not true.
That's why the other triangle balances.
It was saying that the trinity really exists in the,
in-between, right?
Those lines that go between the triangle.
You could even show arrows on there that,
that talk about the relationships between father, son,
spirit, the son, begotten spirit proceeding.
We could get into that a long time, but,
but really this is the only way we can distinguish
between the persons of the Trinity
because God is one, right?
So father, son Spirit are really the same except
for the fact that God's revealed it like this,
the relationships with the Father, son, and spirit.
That's the only way we know any difference on our side.
That's what we call the economic trinity.
That we, we meet the trinity in those ways.
So I can try to explain it, but, but we need to go back
and see what people have actually done to formulate words
that will help us have good language about this.
One of those, the foundational statements is called the nice
scene creed, uh, spoke against heresies that,
that were at the time especially,
but even today saying Jesus was created by the Father
and Jesus is lesser than the Father in some way.
And, and this was originally written in 3 25,
so many years ago, 3 25 ad but then enlarged in 3 81.
And and in part it says this,
we're gonna put on the screen, it's on your notes.
It says, we believe in one God, the Father almighty, maker
of heaven and earth, of all things visible and invisible.
And in one Lord Jesus Christ, the only begotten son of God,
begotten from the Father
before all ages, light from light,
true God from true God, begotten, not made
of one substance with the Father
and in the Holy Spirit, the Lord
and life giver who proceeds from the Father, who
with the Father and the Son is together, worshiped
and together glorified a lot of words.
I get it. But these were church fathers we might say,
who were thinking about how do we explain
what God's word says?
And they formulated this phrasing
and there's a lot more to, I just cut out that part
of it here that says things about the trinity.
Now lemme give you a, a couple keys.
I know this is technical. Keep tracking with me on this.
The key in all this is the distinction between person
and substance or being or essence.
And you hear the word essential in the word essence, right?
That which is essential to what something is.
Okay? So, so let me give you an example.
Like me, what kind of being am I?
Why are you so slow with that? Why? Come on.
Human being right? Like, I don't know.
Okay. Students thought you'd be all over that one, right?
Um, human being, okay, well
the fact that God is one is essential to his being,
to who he is.
So Deuteronomy six, four is very clear with this hero,
Israel, the Lord our God, the Lord is one.
That's just what God is, is one. We are monotheists.
Big word that just means we believe in one God, mono one,
theists God, one God, the being
yet personhood is different.
It's how someone is known.
So yes, I'm a human being,
but I'm known as John Wolgemuth, right?
So that's, that's a unique human.
That's some, that's a person.
That's, that's the characteristics
that I am just like you are unique as a human known as
who you are, the person.
So the, the three persons of the Trinity is
how God has revealed himself.
That's how we know him as father, son, holy Spirit.
Yet again, still one God.
It's almost, you could think like person is personality
or qualities.
The the conceptual idea
or theme of a person, like what comes to mind
when you think about fill in the blank somebody's name.
And it's not just that they're a being, it's
that there's a person there.
And so that I, I put another quote from
another creed on your notes.
This one is the Ahan nation creed written
around the fifth century.
Again, heresies were popping up all around then.
And so here's what they said.
Notice the essence person's language.
We worship one God in Trinity
and Trinity in unity, neither confounding the persons
nor dividing the essence.
For there is one person of the Father, another of the Son,
and another of the Holy Spirit.
But the Godhead of the Father of the Son
and of the Holy Spirit is all one.
The glory equal the majesty co-eternal, such
as the Father is such as the Son
and such as the Holy Spirit.
So again, God eternally exists as three persons, father,
son, holy Spirit.
Each person is fully God. There's no subordinate in that.
And there is one God, not three,
one in three, three in one.
That's the idea we're getting to now
already you're sitting there like, but,
but what questions are coming up?
So there, there's always, there's questions.
Immediately you start to face the challenge of the trinity.
So I just spent a few minutes walking through the basic idea
of the Trinity, but there's a challenge
or challenges that automatically come up
as we start talking about this.
One of the first pushbacks on this idea of the Trinity is
that it's not in the Bible, right?
This that's not there. You guys
are just making this stuff up.
So like we're just putting it all together Later.
We kind of figured it out.
Now we're putting it back into it.
Now it is true that the word trinity is never in the Bible,
But the concept is all over it.
And so we're gonna see one evidence of that just today, uh,
shortly in Mark one, nine through 11.
So go ahead and grab your copy of God's word.
Turn there with me. I want you to see this from God's word.
We're not just going to talk about a lecture
about the trinity today.
This is in God's word. We're gonna study a little bit
around it and in it
and then jump around to some other passages.
But Rome, uh, mark one,
The context here is that the other miracle baby
around Christmas, remember Jesus wasn't the only miracle.
Baby at Christmas was unique, but,
but John the Baptist was also uniquely given
and God had called him to prepare the way of the Messiah.
And so John was out in the wilderness proclaiming the
people's need to repent and be baptized.
Because Mark one look at verses seven
and eight says, he preached saying after me.
So this is why John was even out there preaching.
He says, after me comes he who is mightier than I,
the strap of who sandals.
I'm not worthy to stoop down and untie.
I've baptized you with water,
but he will baptize you with the Holy Spirit.
So he recognizes something is about to happen
that is way bigger than what he's doing.
And look at what happens next.
This is really the kickoff of Jesus's public ministry.
He lived in obscurity for 30 years. Now he shows up.
Look at this, verses nine through 11.
In those days, Jesus came from Nazareth of Galilee
and was baptized by John in the Jordan.
And when he came up outta the water, just,
just imagine this scene in your head when he came up out
of the water, immediately he saw the heavens being torn open
and the spirit descending on him like a dove.
And a voice came from heaven.
You are my beloved son
With you, I'm well pleased.
This is one of the most explicit evidences
of the Trinity and scripture.
All three persons of God are involved in this moment, right?
You have the, the person of the Father
speaking about his beloved son.
You have Jesus the Son being baptized.
You have the spirit hovering down right away
that defeats one of the heresies called modalism,
which believes that the one God merely shows up in different
forms at different times, different modes.
Well, this, this is
because then it's just Father here, Jesus there Spirit.
No, this right here, they're all three involved.
Now I know it can be confusing
'cause it sure seems like they're
separate entities, right?
The Father, son Spirit, they're, they're separate.
Like there's some kind of tri theism.
I said, we're monotheists. This says are, are we Tri theus?
Actually, well that's why we can't take just this verse
in isolation from the rest of God's word.
We can actually piece this together from all over the Bible,
especially the New Testament.
Matthew 1127, all things have been handed over to me.
Jesus says by my father,
no one knows the son except the Father.
And no one knows the Father except the son
and anyone to whom the son chooses to reveal him.
You have just a page earlier from
what we were reading in Mark Matthew 28,
the Great Commission.
We talk about this all the time. Notice what it says.
Jesus came and said to them,
all authority in heaven on earth has been given to me.
Go therefore make disciples of all nations,
baptizing them in the name of the Father and of the Son
and of the Holy Spirit teaching them
to observe all that I've commanded you.
Behold I am with you always to the end of the age.
You hear that even when we do baptisms here, right?
Father Son Spirit, there's this
Trinitarian idea of baptism.
Luke chapter one, the Holy Spirit conceived a baby in Mary's
womb that would be called holy the Son of God.
You can go read John 14 through 16, those three chapters,
it's full, where Jesus is talking about his relationship
with the Father, the sending of the Holy Spirit.
It's all over those three chapters.
Think about Acts two, after Jesus had ascended,
the Holy Spirit miraculously filled God's people
to declare God's works fulfilling Old Testament prophecy.
Romans eight, like the pinnacle of Romans, says,
God worked through the spirit of life in Christ Jesus
to set us free from the law of sin and death.
He even equates the spirit of God with the spirit of Christ,
which prompts us to say, Abba Father,
it's all right there.
One Corinthians 12, the Spirit says it's the only way we can
say Jesus' Lord, like so us even
to be seeing Jesus means the spirit has
to be working the spirit gifts, believers
for faith and action.
Galatians four, God sent forth,
his son sent forth the spirit of the son as well.
Ephesians one, there's the father's role, the son's role,
the spirit's role in our salvation.
And then Jude chapter one, the only chapter verses 20
and 21 says this,
but you beloved, building yourselves up in your most holy
faith, praying in the Holy Spirit,
keep yourselves in the love of God, waiting for the mercy
of our Lord Jesus Christ that leads to eternal life.
So the pushback on the Trinity not being in the
Bible is false.
You just saw it, right?
There's, there's even hints in the Old Testament.
You can go through and find those as well.
But even as I say that, that's absent from the Bible, that
that's a challenge brought against us.
Well there's another usually one that follows.
It's that, okay, well the Trinity is
just beyond our reasoning.
It's, it's absent from the Bible.
Okay, well then we've answered that,
but no, okay, well then it's just beyond our reasoning.
It's too much for us. Now we can't understand this.
I mean, yeah, we could take all those verses,
mash something together philosophically,
but we really can't reason it out.
It sounds so outlandish. It sounds crazy.
We can't think of anything.
And in one way that is actually true.
We cannot come to faith by reason alone.
We can't deduce it out. So I get it.
It's difficult to, to think about this idea,
but really we only have two choices here.
We can be Unitarian, where God is exclusively one,
which is what Islam says, which is what Judaism says.
Others would say that that God is exclusively one.
That's one option. Or we could be Trinitarian
this one in three, three in one idea.
And, and yes, it's a mystery.
We just have to live in that mystery for a while.
Yet. Yet here's, here's
what happens when we have those challenges come our way
because of that, we face those in the trinity.
That can lead us to some dangers.
If we're not careful, if we don't learn to speak well
of this doctrine, we can get in trouble.
The dangers of the Trinity.
Here's the first danger is that we can hold wrong ideas.
Okay? It's hard. Yes, we have to think.
But that means we can also hold wrong ideas about the
trinity, about God in general.
This is what we call heresy.
And this is throughout history, it's been this way.
When it's wrong, ideas about God, that's heresy.
And even metaphors can be this way.
Now, analogies are helpful in some ways.
They just cannot stand for the whole.
Like you will not be able
to explain the trinity with one analogy.
And so I wanna give you some examples, right?
So we can help explain subsections.
But let me give you some examples.
You might've heard this one. God is like water
where you can find water in three different forms.
You have solid liquid and vapor.
Well, the problem is that is called modalism, where it just
says that God is not three distinct persons,
but merely reveals himself in three different forms, right?
'cause water cannot be all three at the same time.
It's either an iceberg or vapor
or water at that moment.
So a steaming iceberg is not helpful
to us getting forward in this idea.
What about God is the Son?
You might've heard this one same picture from
before, that there's a star, right?
And it creates light. It creates heat.
Sends those off from it.
And you think that's a good analogy.
Well, actually that's called Arianism, which said,
which is one of these creeds written against it
that the father created the son.
The Father created the spirit.
That there's subordination in that.
Which by the way is not an old heresy.
It's alive and well today. It's called Mormonism.
It's called Jehovah's Witnesses
That Say Jesus was created that makes them
un-Christian in their beliefs.
Here's another common example.
Three, three leaf clover, right?
This, this, that's helpful, right? There's three parts.
But notice the word parts.
That's partialism, which says that the father, son,
and spirit are merely parts of God.
That they're one third each to make up the whole.
But that's, that's not all of God then, right?
Or that the same man could be a husband,
a father, and an employer.
That's modalism again.
Or like the an egg, maybe you thought of an egg
that the shell and the white
and the yolk are all parts of the egg.
That's partialism again, right?
You see how these, these metaphors can be so
helpful in some ways, but really unhelpful.
'cause it drifts into heresy actually very quickly,
aspects illustrated.
Yes. But they can't deliver all the goods.
So what can happen then?
If there's a possibility we hold wrong ideas about the
Trinity, well then we just throw our hands up
and say, I'm gonna forget it all.
I don't even need to know anything.
I'm gonna ignore all ideas about the Trinity.
I don't even wanna know anything
because I'm gonna get it wrong.
We say forget it and ignore all ideas.
But that's wrong too, isn't it?
First, here's, here's the thing.
I said this a couple weeks ago in a revelation if,
if even if you try to not have beliefs about God,
you will believe something.
Because we're all theologians at heart.
We all have this understanding of God in some way
written on us and even then believed in us.
And so we need to have as correct beliefs about God
as we can continually growing in
that we must try to understand God more.
But we should also see it's important
because God's word says it's important.
We ought to think rightly about who God is
as he's revealed himself in his word.
That's why we shouldn't throw our hands up
and say, I'm gonna ignore everything about this.
I don't even need to think about it.
No, God's word says it's important.
So we need to make it important.
That leads us to the necessity of the Trinity.
Why is this so important? Why is this such a big deal?
Why is it a big rock?
Like why is it one of the things that we put in first?
We can't leave it out.
Why does this matter first?
Because then we understand God better.
We need to study this so that we understand God better.
Like I just said, it shouldn't.
We want to understand and know God better.
Like shouldn't we hunger?
Shouldn't we thirst to grasp more of who God is?
And we saw this some last week with God's attributes, but
but again, as I grew this week in my theological
understanding of the Trinity, like I just sat here
at my desk, I just sat stunned
that this God
that I could not fully conceive of,
I'm still still asking questions.
But then the more you grow in it,
the more you're just stunned in awe
and love for who He's, I mean,
just think God is so big beyond comprehension.
He's eternal. He's omnipotent. He's the creator.
He's the sovereign one.
He is one in three, three in one, able to be
and do that in a way we could never understand.
This is who God is.
Yet at the same time, he is all of that.
Not in an aloof separated kind of way,
but like he's some watchmaker up there, clock maker,
setting it in stone, letting it go.
And he's completely separated from it.
No, he is near to us at the same time.
Deuteronomy 31, 8.
It is the Lord that's Yahweh who goes before you.
He will be with you. He will not leave you nor forsake you.
Do not fear or be dismayed.
So listen, when you think about how big God is,
how massive incomprehensible he is,
and then he says to you, I'm gonna be with you.
Is that not a measure of confidence?
And no matter what you face, like no matter
what I'm walking into this week
that God says, I am with
You.
What courage, what joy,
what peace that
Comes from that.
And so it helps us understand God better.
So we know him better and we love him more.
And we have confidence that this God of the universe is for
Us, But we also need the Trinity
to help us understand salvation better.
Like we understand God better because of this,
but to understand salvation better.
See, when we think about salvation, it's easy for us
to think that Jesus was on some solo mission,
that Jesus was doing his own thing.
And it's really cool that he did it,
but we kind of leave him on his own.
But that's wrong. And it actually limits
the beauty and power of our salvation
'cause Listen, before the foundation of the world,
God existed in perfect community, perfect fulfillment.
He is self-sustaining. He needs nothing.
We saw that Acts 17 last week.
He does not have to do anything outside of himself. Yet.
What did God do?
Think about what he did. How does
it help us understand salvation?
What did he do? What we see revealed in scripture is
that God, the Father, created the universe
and he predestined and he called to salvation.
God, the Son took on flesh to save us
and make us like him.
And then God, the Spirit sanctifies us,
makes us the holy temple of God in him.
That's what he did. He didn't have to, he didn't need,
he wasn't looking ahead like he wasn't wanting the
pitter-patter of little feet in heaven,
and he was lacking something.
So he is, I'm gonna create people and I'm gonna save them.
He didn't need anything. And yet he chose
to create, know it was gonna fall apart, save,
redeem, sanctify.
He did all of that.
But remember this, the three persons
of the Trinity were not working on their own.
There's only one will in God.
And that will in the Trinity was to
Save.
That's what he did, does will do.
And the whole Trinity involved in every part of salvation.
So don't think the Son does this, the Father's act.
No, the Father also redeems the Father also sanctifies the
Son also was a part of creation, right?
Hebrews one, the Spirit was also redeeming creating.
That's all part of it.
I love what Gregory of Nazi Anis said in the 300 said,
this, no sooner do I place before the mind the one, no.
No sooner do I think about the one than I'm surrounded
by the splendor of the three.
No sooner do I distinguish the three than I'm brought back
to the one when any one of the three appears to me.
I think of him as a whole.
When again, I consider the three together I perceive,
but one splendor and I cannot divide or measure the light.
That is one. So just know this,
that when we sing these songs to Jesus
as the king, we mean the triune God.
Also, right? When we ask the Spirit
to help us avoid sin, we mean Trinity.
Father, help spirit, help son help. Just think.
Just think how that opens up.
The power involved in our salvation.
This is all of God involved in all of salvation
because here's this, here's this reality.
The problem we have with sin is that it's against God.
And so we need all of God
to be involved in all of our salvation.
There's not parts, not components working against each other
or in any way to combat one another.
All of God is involved in all of our salvation.
So listen, this is a mystery,
but it is so foundational for our
Faith.
But I want you to be clear in your head, as I've wrestled
with this all week, that it's okay for this to be so far
beyond us because if God
was small enough for our finite brains to understand him,
he wouldn't be big enough to save us.
We need God to be this big.
Then he can be our savior. Romans 11 says it very well.
Oh, the depth of the riches and wisdom and knowledge of God.
How unsearchable are his judgements?
How inscrutable
or uncorrectable are his ways for who has known the mind
of the Lord or who has been His counselor?
God is God. We are
not yet.
He has told us about himself A
and even better.
He has come to us to save us.
How great is our God? Amen.
Amen. Amen.